this is a physical manifestation of love
this is glorious and beautiful and any
god which denies me for this don't have
a part on the left-hand side
can I have my LGBTQ folks on the
right-hand side and I have my
conservatives there are times when I
feel uncomfortable expressing my views
around sexuality I am uncomfortable
primarily because the bromance like well
there's two girls who's the boy and then
it really just breaks the ice as us like
there isn't supposed to be a boy that's
why we're there I do my best to break
the ice with the comedic deflection
which I've learned is is a self defense
mechanism I come from a very
conservative community and so you know
it just wasn't talked about the people
I've had the most conversation with
about are actually my family which is
really weird because I came out to my
parents because my dad was going to be
leading the protests at the Pride
Festival that my boyfriend want me to go
to so I'm a pastor as well I'm also a
community leader in Boyle Heights and in
that community there's a large LGBTQ
presence so there's that fear of really
coming out and say what I believe
because I do love everybody and I don't
want to be pushed to the side just
because I have a certain feeling about
you know any topic really
I just wanted to say - and you know it's
not the beliefs that sometimes I have a
problem with her I think people have a
problem with in general it's just like
the actions from the belief so like it's
okay to have beliefs but if we like can
be loving in our beliefs and you know
how our actions come from those beliefs
and like I love that we're having this
conversation you know like trying to
breach those like build a bridge some
sins are worse than others in the eyes
of you know of the God our worship I
believe that any sin separates us from
him because he's holy and impure but at
the same time I think there are certain
sins that will have greater consequences
with that for me it would be you know
killing another human is the worst
that's it
also it Venn diagrams into abortion
taking the life of another is huge
is huge can I ask you to this do you all
see homosexuality as a sin yes and if so
where on that scale I don't think a
homosexual tendency or an attraction to
somebody of the same gender is a sin I
think that's a natural feeling I think
when you start engaging in a lifestyle
and you act upon that tendency then
because it goes against what I believe
God designed then I think that's clearly
a sin I just don't believe in sin
because I feel that sometimes being
punitive about things can like make you
repress things and like instinctually I
was like but not acting on them would be
a sin like that's how it feels for me
like being dishonest to myself that
feels wrong at some point in my life I
was taught that sex is wrong
I guess like within the context you know
sexes that aside the context of marriage
and so I guess that's how identified
with the question I had a very strong
religious upbringing and I ended up
doing a lot of self-harm and I end up
doing a lot of things just to try and
cope with these urges that when I
finally gave in to them I mean this is
this is a physical manifestation of love
this is glorious and beautiful and any
God which denies me for this I don't
have a part of because whatever this is
is I I know for a fact to be a truth
because it is the nature of love yeah
just responding to your story it makes
me sad to hear that that you decided to
hurt yourself yeah I still hold on to
what I believe are my beliefs but at the
same time I wish there was a better way
for you to talk to someone and to
process and to think through reconciling
how you feel with like what you may have
been taught or have read through
Scripture yeah I mean and that's the
thing is I think there's a lot of
there's a lot of cultural baggage I
think around Christianity that isn't
necessarily inherently part of any
biblical Christianity even though I grew
up in a Christian family I was I don't
recall ever being told that sex was
wrong or it was a bad thing I think I
grew up with the understanding that sex
is a beautiful thing it was given to us
as a gift to enjoy there's a place where
it's it's been designed for a place
where we can enjoy it and there's a
place where it's it's detestable in the
sight of the Creator the one who gave it
to us I just don't like the idea that
anything is really detestable you know
what I mean so I just don't you say that
even in sex for you within certain
context is testable I like like if it's
not like that's pretty detestable
yeah I agree the things that
consent to our I think not like that I
have sometimes no control over if it's
not consensual people should honor the
pronouns others wish to be called I'm
all for this like I identify as they
people don't consider it and I think
that like having these conversations
about how people want to identify it's
like really important in a way that we
can move things forward and stuff yeah
if you're like hey if you don't use
whatever you're gonna get fined or
whatever like that's I'm not a big fan
of that other conversations yeah but
otherwise it's just being respectful oh
the pronoun police so for me I never
correct people because many times people
do confuse me yes sir I don't it doesn't
faze me however I'm born in a female
body I'm ashy there are times where my
girlfriend's have said all my boyfriend
isn't that just because of their comfort
zone they don't want to have to deal
with the whole like social stigma so
you're comfortable with them presenting
you as a as a male it doesn't faze me
really it doesn't faze me at all because
my identity and my expressions are
masculine and I've come to the terms and
the realization that I don't need to
chop up my body into different pieces to
fit in the social little box that is man
if you want to address me you can
address me as he or she or them or girl
Becky with the good hair I bet it
doesn't as long as the term is
respectful yeah I will take it I mean I
step back just because it's a
complicated topic cuz with language
language is powerful and so when
somebody who I would consider a female
wants to be called a male I would want
to probably respect that but I still
firmly believe that you know they're
like God created their to be men and a
woman and I would like to sit down and
talk to that person in depth before
meaning one way or the other
yeah but I think like focusing more on
like building a relationship instead of
just like grilling someone why do you
feel you know what I mean like just
trying what's wrong with you like why
don't ya
it's like you like America is heading in
the right direction when it comes to
inclusion and diversity
if for me it's more like the youth are
headed in like inclusion and diversity
and I wouldn't necessarily say it's the
institutions of power I think the youth
are really moving our culture forward
and like it's encouraging to see now I
can't imagine what it's like to not be
able to be Who I am and having to hide
so I think it's good in that sense that
people finally are living in awe in a
world where I can be Who I am and I
don't have to be ostracized and I can be
included and the reason why I didn't
step in is because you know I have
certain values that I think are from God
and so that's why I hesitated a little
bit on do I come forward or not well I
have a question because I you know I'm
curious where the sanctity if your
marriage comes in like if you can only
get married to one because you and God
and that woman have a relationship that
is perfect for you I'm curious how that
affects who we can marry yeah I don't
think the job of a Christian for example
is to get people to behave in a certain
moral way that's in line with what the
Bible says I wouldn't be one to say you
can't marry you can't marry another guy
or you can't marry another girl I would
say first of all God loves you you know
God loves you
yeah so specifically talking about like
prop 8
when prop 8 came out I was completely
against it I thought it was foolish and
and quite ignorant and by many churches
supporting prop 8 we basically tell you
told the gay community that we don't
care about you we don't care about how
you feel what you think love is we're
just gonna mandate that you can't marry
who you say you want to marry
we're adversaries yeah we became
adversaries and the church
I think lost a great position and saying
and coming to people saying like we love
you
people should have the right to have sex
with anyone they want and you okay yeah
all right consensually all right with
anyone I okay yes
in the term anyone except children yeah
as humans we and as creatures of a
divine spirit we have the right to
follow our instincts and our sexual
urges without punishing ourselves for
you know wanting a woman or wanting a
man and say I knew anyone has a right to
consensual lovemaking so the the reason
why I step back and I you guys would
agree with me but when I was 9 years old
I was touched by a family member
and so you know that I can't step
forward when and that question is asked
and I know you guys wouldn't agree with
that and that's you you preference at
the very beginning that you know if at
long is consensual and not kids but that
was my experience and yep sorry about
that
I resonate with as well I mean I was as
well you know and there wasn't a family
member thank God however still enough of
a tumultuous problem that even when I
came out as a lesbian I wondered if it
had to do with that instant and
definitely brought up and that's why it
was the first thing that I said you know
because you know one is innocent and
doesn't know absolutely
I believe in a higher power I'd love to
hear from your perspective why you why
you believe in a higher power I mean the
household I was raised in why not
the analogy of like you can't one cannot
see love one cannot see air and it's
still there and you know I started going
to more clergymen and wanting to
understand exactly you know my ways of
being in the image of a greater creator
understanding I wasn't a mistake you
know you know there is a higher source
there's definitely something that has
given me these blessings that have
nothing to do with me it has everything
to do with a bigger picture of things I
think for me you know I was also raised
in a very strong religious background
and just as I cannot deny this part of
me that is the way I express love
I'd be dishonest if I said that when I
sat down and I prayed and I listened I
didn't hear no it's time for the heathen
i resonate with some of the things you
said to like I do believe in a higher
power I just don't believe in like a
typical higher power and I also like
highly believe in science so I'm like I
believe in gravity as a higher power I
believe in like entropy is that you know
like things that we that are out of our
control and stuff and I want to always
keep searching and always keep
questioning and like always trying to
find like as much love as possible I
guess and I believe in other people's
gods too like I believe in that for
y'all you know what I mean like if
that's what makes you a better person
and makes you feel more yourself and
feel more loved like I believe in that
you know but I can't say that I believe
it for myself because I I don't know I
don't want to cast my it all my eggs on
that's good guys thank you friends thank
you
[Music]
hey guys this is jason from jubilee here
we hope you enjoyed another episode of
middle ground we'd love to hear from you
in the comments below let us know what
you thought about the episode let us
know what you thought about the issue
and whether there was someone who
changed your opinion or if there's
something that you agreed with disagree
with we'd love to have a great
discussion with you in the comments as
always make sure you click here to
subscribe click here for more videos
[Music]